hasta las 17 horas de hoy más de 156
millones de brasileños van a tener que
renovar el congreso y el senado y
escoger al nuevo presidente de Brasil
Según todos los sondeos el ex presidente
Luis y nace Luna da Silva es el favorito
con un 50% de intención de votos y el
actual mandatario tendría un
36%. estamos en un colegio en el centro
de Río de Janeiro y aquí también los
electores se preguntan si será necesaria
una segunda vuelta para tener los
resultados
mi expectativa como militante es que
resolvamos estas elecciones en la
primera vuelta pero dado que soy
analista y politólogo dijo que las
posibilidades son muy parecidas no hay
Cómo adivinar estamos votando sin saber
lo que va a pasar hoy
creo que va a haber segunda vuelta entre
bolsonaro y Lula están casi empatados
porque la tercera vía prácticamente no
existe en este país la elección será
entre ellos dos pero creo que bolsonaro
va a ganar en la segunda vuelta
Espero que
no hayan ido en relación al resultado de
las elecciones estoy deseando que todo
se desarrollen calma independientemente
del resultado yo creo que las
consecuencias de un golpe o algo más
brusco Sería pésimo para nuestro país
la otra gran pregunta es si el
presidente
impugnará los resultados alegando
posibilidades de fraude el Tribunal
Superior electoral ha dicho en varias
ocasiones que las urnas electrónicas son
seguras la otra duda es si puede haber
disturbios en la calle en caso de
Victoria en la primera vuelta de Lula
esta noche sabremos que va a acontecer
en Brasil